the squint Ana we had just finished
describing the airfield that jean-claude
Paul's ranch in Haiti and you had agreed
at that at that time there was no
cloture on the deal is that correct no
what was the status of the deal this
totally the deal was that I was going to
come back to Miami and this guy friend
of mine he was gonna get encounter with
the people see who he was gonna hire to
go to Haiti so did you
let's go back to the airstrip and I want
you to relate to me what took place at
the airstrip as you complete now the
you've driven 1.6 miles you got a long
airstrip where do we go okay from that
point you know he told us he told all
the drooling pangs and the full of all
the type of gasoline that we need and
then he took us back to the house while
we're sitting in the house
this friend of mine start asking
questions what kind of Lies they mr.
Paul when he sighed the house and
brought two lies in his hand to show us
that to what lights
he took lights to show you what the
lighting of the runway would be like it
was because the plan was for him to land
at night apparently you know he one else
to lying on lion night and the reason
was when he told us that he's a friend
of mine told tolling what we need like
you know for that so he went inside the
house I'm provide us with two samples of
the lighting light he was kind of square
lighting with the plastic cover we're
two color red and a blue then he told us
to follow him to inside the house when
he had a big room there were more lies
and more lights more lies electric bombs
flash lies and you know so Oh God
equipments radios okay so your friend
was now convinced that it was possible
to do the landing yes then what did you
do well from that point that time his
brother came home whose brother came out
Antonia Paul
jean-claude Paul's brother yes Antonio
Paul came over and couple all the
military guys were playing clothes and I
was talking we were fellow my friend
told me it's anywhere he could have a
pitchman
for all of them together and every
so your friend took a picture of all of
you standing there
the picture was to bite me rather
Illinois oh my mrs. Delano Lea is that
picture where is that picture today
peaches viejas DEA has that picture now
yes okay that's been placed in evidence
before the grand jury that I know yes
now after the picture was taken
what did you do after that we had a
couple of champagne bottle that you open
hang he taught us of champagne yes you
open bottles of champagne to celebrate a
deal yes you know to be like the VIP
treatment again and he told us to feel
what her lunch he want to take us to a
restaurant in port-au-prince so we agree
and we all went to port-au-prince what I
mean we all when he's a friend of mine
me miss Dylan or John crop all the
restaurant was located right next to the
American Embassy so when we walk into
the restaurant he was a lot of people
there from the American Embassy and some
Haitians also eating there some people
look at him like he was afraid of him
and run away look at the table um say
something to me right Dylan oi I didn't
understand that he turn around and say
something to me rail said something to
his wife so his wife has a walking so we
sit down and be on the table he told us
Mireille told us the hospital saying you
know the couple of guy who was sitting
right at the restaurant the war for da
canna CIA and graffiti I already know
that
later we found down through mere dil
annoy that he has some kind of counter
to the American Embassy
inside American Embassy he was a Haitian
woman who supply information to him to
jean-claude Paul yes okay now who was to
make arrangements for the pilots to fly
the arrangement was made to talk I mean
we supposed to make the arrangement for
a pilot to fly did you actually see the
cocaine we saw the sample he supplied to
us and we still have the jar with the
earth fire six thousand you know in our
packing did you bring that back to Miami
no well we really my friend the total
weight the cooking in the bathroom in
the airplane you went you put it in the
airplane yes well let me go back senator
that's what eating you know and he asked
my friend if he liked the quality a my
friend tolling yes but he needs to take
this sample back to Miami from the man
from were facing is and then every time
they will go to the airport to get out
of Haiti since you always leave us si
they always check out back in the way
out so it's no way we could take the
cocaine with us so he told us it was no
no problem
no whatever so we finish eating and he
drove us to the airport
and he went down himself and to the
cookie jar right his handbag with his
gun was and he was right through the
immigration and US Coast ambien in case
of custom who did that joke RuPaul yeah
with the Jericho Kane right so he went
through the security system the alarm
sound I'm the sole you turn around when
they saw who it was far away everybody
shallow him coming went right through
and then he gave you the jar to take on
the airplane yes so he escorted you
right to the airplane
okay and then while you were on the
airplane your friend thought better
bringing it in
you know I told him you know what the
hell you want to bring this thing to
Miami you know you probably get caught
with this thing for hours you know but
it thrown away so he apparently decided
to do that he went to the restroom come
down the jar in the Rose Room jump the
contents yes but he kept the jar how
don't recorded on Senate if he kept it
here not sure about that
all right now did the deal something
happen to this deal correct yes okay you
want to describe to us what happened
well the deal didn't go through his
planned right okay why not well the
reason we were about to wait at me miss
venom I already stopped made contacts
you know to whom how he was gonna bring
it in
he caught a couple of people in Bo's an
airplane and he was walking on it so the
following day I mean just he was working
at making the deal carry out no your
friend was out there trying to put the
pieces together just like me and
something happened while he was doing
that well the reason I wrote that
annoying I arrived in Miami that
following day after we laugh and he told
us the antonio paul and associates was
very scared about the picture that we
took of the film
so she told us that you know I'm Tony
was gonna arrive in Miami and the next
following day to pick out those pictures
and then-
how was the one who to the picture to
developer and we took into the place in
Miami without me knowing you know it's
one of those deals that you develop
adderall and they keep you two copies
Hey
so when Antonio arrived in Miami oh you
know what you about the negative I'm one
of the copies I would get one of the
copies you kept lying like that yes all
right then what happened Tony Atala was
the Meirelles got no authorization to
dealing anything I'll go slow here
Antonio Paul Colonel Paul's brother came
to Miami collected a picture and the
negative and then he told you then the
myriad Illinois has no business or North
to the fish at all to be in this deal
okay
so mrs. delle Noi was cut off from the
deal well they did was she start
screaming right away and she called John
clobbering Haiti I'm between them they
were they work out the if you did he was
going to go through and the Haitians
paid you money just how much money
you've been paid they keep me he was
gonna give me hundred thousand dollars
which I open a letter a career in the
ocean bank in Miami but you'd come with
a hundred thousand dollars back from
Haiti she keeping their money in Miami
that week later on that week
what was that money for well according
to her you know it wasn't her money how
did she want to that was the investment
money first money that was the money
that sort of enticed you into this deal
this is that right mm-hmm
okay now so she's now making a lot of
noise because she's supposedly
deauthorized from dealing with you
correct it's like me and then what
happens
well what happened was you know she
called the husband in a parameter
Hospital green to pay her $50,000 see
the DA go through because you don't know
if he was gonna do the deal that has to
be made by Antonia Paul decision I want
to make sure I understand this
he agreed to pay her $50,000 yeah in
order to do what service any way I can
talk to the translation because my boy
is killing me okay well we'll try to do
it that way and see how it works but I'd
like you to talk into the microphone in
Spanish anyway and ask the interpreter
and just do it a sentence at a time so
what happened
take when you see me win the all 0
anymore call me little annoying yelling
ah Antonio II know you know what I want
to do what we've done so well and we
don't have that much more to do I want
to try to keep it going in English it's
just gonna be quicker and you're gonna
have to talk the same amount no matter
what but if I'd ask you just to go slow
I think you'll have an easier time if
you don't try to talk as rapidly and you
can talk softer you can talk a little
softer and I think we're still here so
just explain to me she was going to get
paid $50,000 from her husband kernels
all that's right to replace part of the
money yes okay what would happen to the
deal happening to the deal was there
with Antonio arrived we had a meaning we
and Morel and Antonio and he told us you
know first he wants the pictures back
and the negative which were given back
to him and also that you know if he's
any debts have to be done
they gotta be done with him and his
brother in the mirror l do not she was
not authorized to do the deal all right
then what happened
then and she was very mad about the
answer and she got the phone and called
junk appalled when she talked to him in
a panic jean-claude Paul thought his
brother on the phone too at the same
time if anything go through he was gonna
give her a finding fee of $50,000 so you
tried to keep the deal alive we tried to
keep the deal of unity with you and she
would get 50,000 yes what happened then
to the deal well there was Antonio is
town asking questions about us asking
guy you know he don't know us yeah you
know he began to not feel sure he could
trust you that's right then what
happened well he he thought lost you
know he's he was gonna go back to Haiti
I'm talked to the associates to see what
they're gonna say about this deal but
something very strange happened he was
gonna take Miami one more day and you
need somebody to come around with him to
buy our Maurice Parr soon I didn't
understand it he did what he needs
somebody to talk quietly he needs
somebody to go with him the next
following day around Miami to buy some
harmony parts by automotive parts he has
been video wouldn't mind to take him
around
right so you took him around Miami by
automotive parts just then what happened
well you know what driving and talking
we start building a good relationship he
invited me to go to Haiti you know to
maybe walk it out the details in this
deal he went back to Haiti he went back
to Haiti let me try to shortcut this a
little and the deal was agreed on again
the agree was agree with a condition
that I gotta go by can sit down we all
Dame again did you know did you went
back and sat down with them one more
time I went back and this time
we went back only my partner me and
Antonio pickles on the airport come from
there we went to the deselect barracks
we don't fall once again you sat down
was wrong call Paul as you close the
deal yes okay and this was done right in
the dessaline barracks he was downgraded
easily embarrassed and from there we
have dinner and after that you returned
to Miami after that my friend returned
to Miami and I stay in Haiti where I'm
Tony appalled how his girls guess how
long did you stay in Haiti how do record
a senator but it was about three or four
days at some time did a plane come to
pick up the drugs no okay at some time
did the drugs come no and the reason for
that was the reason for that was because
my friend went back to Miami to made the
arrangement and the arrangements were
made correct
he made the arrangement after he got the
OK with Antonio and young crop all that
idea was gonna go on did the deal go off
no way on the deal went on that's what I
mean
yeah okay the the deal was then carried
out correct yes okay and the drugs were
sent to the United States well if you
don't want the details how happen you
guys wanted to I want to try to shorten
trying to save your voice and make it
easy to understand yes but but something
happened to those narcotics on their way
correct yes you didn't get them no okay
what happened to them
well what happened was that they are the
people who flew the narcotics that these
friend of mine hired three puffs the law
and Spanish TV Bahamas let's be clear
about that pilots were hired to run the
drugs in yes but the pilots who were
hired as you said quote ripped off the
load another pilot other people who roam
the
the the the pilot was a guy that they
rode used to fly the plane the guy who
owned the plane and the people who was
running for him
reap off the drugs a guy who owned the
plane had people who were working for
him rip off the drugs from the pilots
mmm
so you lost the drugs no money to pay
the Haitians correct
luckily so the Haitians come and they
want their money mmm that's what the
nightmare is starting that's what that's
what the nightmare started and what
happened well you know we first you know
what's taught by this guy Frank and then
the drug stealing is control then he was
waiting for better with a time I wanted
it I didn't understand it okay sure and
I wanna make a point before this meeting
with the Haitian had never met the
people who owned the plane the people
was gonna bring the drugs him Bahamas
come didn't know anybody
nobody knew anybody my friend knows the
people he's the one who hired him but he
never tell me what it was okay the
reason is in what point let me make a
point when was closely deal
John claw Paul Tonio the TI was gonna go
on from the condition that I guarantee
to you because this is random I didn't
have nothing no property no way to be
tried
so you're the guarantor for this deal
going on inside of your friend and you
stood to make $100,000 no sir I stood to
make $100,000 100,000 users okay and you
took steps to get the money back correct
yes you tried to get the drugs back and
it's at that time that you got arrested
by the DEA correct well the guy you know
who floated row from Haiti and some
other place that he was a drug dealer
guy it was he got caught up but DEA
hands as a condition for his release he
told da
about the connection that are having
Haiti right he told me he was going to
take me to the place with the people who
run the draw for him he told me to the
DAR from he took you to the DA yes it
was a it was a front operation of the
DEA good and that's when you got in
contact with the DEA yes and they got in
contact with you exactly which is what
brings us to this point today correct
misuk okay so this was your first time
involved with drugs first effort
well my first time do we involve the
Windy criminal and it's safe to say that
you know for $100,000 a very successful
business and a lot of other things have
been disrupted correct yes
now since that time you say that there
have been attempts on your life
by the Haitians you described mm-hmm
I might add for the record that our
staff investigator was present in Miami
meeting with you and in fact was quite
surprised to see machine guns in the
room in which he was meeting with you
and I believe about the half hour after
the investigator left there was an
attempt on your life in the presence of
a DEA agent is that accurate yes would
you describe that to us well you know
after mr. Blum left town I spoke with
DEA office right there and talking about
the situation where this is the case
they soon went out of the DEA building
you know to go home I was followed by
the car with apparently two Haitians and
a Spanish guy sitting right behind this
quarry was at action her godson their
dachshund Nissen
four-door with a tinted windows on this
woman saw him you know I went right back
to the DEA building and I keep the DEA
you know the license plate the car
follow me two times around the building
right in the DEA building in Miami he
saw a couple of state trooper sitting
around so the sooner I got in they took
me inside the DEA building from the
morning about 14 aliens we went out with
me to scope me out of the building 14
agents escorted you out of the bills
including the and did the agents manage
to make arrests at that time know what I
know I know they got the license plate
of the car subsequently some arrests
were made correct yes it was made on
March 6 1987
and you tell me who Lionel Wooley is
playing this tingling liner Willy was
the right man for Yom Kippur in Haiti
he's one of the thumb to McCune where
does he live he beeping what's going on
Miami in Miami and do you know whether
or not he's the man who is alleged to
have put a price on your head according
to the information I got these two a
third party would you mr. Blanc and
confirm that but that's what you believe
yes that's what you've come to learn
from your information yes sir
do you know whether or not members of
the Haitian community in Miami are
active in the manufacture of crack as
you know since this is happening to me
and everywhere they will to come back to
the agent town but I may understand me
yes yeah do you know what the going
price for a crystal of crack is in Miami
schools you don't know no idea
incidentally you know whether or not the
tonton Macoutes
in Miami yes do they operate yes
you know whether or not the drug trade
in Miami involving the Haitians is
controlled from Haiti he's my youngest
thing that he's just and you can tell us
more about that you have told us
privately I know but again you send it
to you have to remember that I wasn't
that able to prove this matter on
person-to-person basis and like Oh light
everything that I got wasn't a third on
basis while you were in Haiti did you
learn from your conversations that there
is a Colombian cartel connection with
Colonel Paul yes and is that connection
ad man by the name of Cardozo the
connections come from the name name is
Escobar who representing the yes the
card also family representing the
Escobar in terms in United States excuse
me a moment you talking about Cardozo Oh
call their own card Elsa let me rephrase
that point Cardozo was the contacts the
Jericho Colonel Claus oh poor poor John
kupo habit we him and the Colombians
that that was my question yes and do you
know if there was a time when the cartel
accused Cardozo of pocketing some of the
money there's a symptom it did happen
and was that money that was sent to him
in order to pay Carl Paul when this
thing in this deal was the Cardozo was
making the payment for the lease in the
field and the security arrangement for
the Columbia true Haiti do you know what
if anything the cartel did to make him
pay it back it's my understanding
Jonathan down where Cardozo was doing
and cordosa was paying John Paul $50,000
for the leasing of the field
part of the same time he was telling the
Columbia and he was paying 350 i'm
pocket $3,000 so when they realized that
company mr. Paul confiscate one of the
chicken for the Colombian confiscated a
shipment shipment and the Columbia
runaway ask why and ask took her
daughter to go to Colombia when they
could we could also went to Colombia
they called John claw Paul and asking
why he was convicted of the Murshid eyes
and hands to eat tolling that he never
got paid he's another witness with mr.
blonde knows who was in the other end of
this deal who can corroborate with more
detail about what happened I understand
that
what was done to mr. Cardozo in order to
deal with this issue again senator get
these for the second person like mr.
blown hands please forgive me you have
this from other people yes yes we have
it from another source
I understand that but you have this from
other sources
yes I got the other own corners wife you
know what was done to mr. I believe they
beat him a burglar in Colombia know what
they did and they tie him to a tree yeah
yeah dice told you where mr. ballon
wasn't the office what do you want to
tell us I want to point mice
understanding in the story according to
the woman who was there he say they mr.
Cardozo was tied up to the tree and the
Columbia was beating him with a bat and
was he forced and to telephone his
family and tell them to get the money
yes his wife and Friends I believe
do you know who controls the Haitian
trade boats on the Miami River if you
don't know I don't want you to guess but
no I'm asking you do you know all right
I do know whether or not those boats are
used for cocaine smuggling he was
mentioned to me one time in Haiti yes
while you're in Haiti you learned that
boy I was 18 that time yeah I wasn't in
Tonio Paul house
he's the one who mentioned to me now is
it common at this point we mean how did
you know I mean one strike that why did
you go out and get a machine gun why
didn't you ask the DEA at that point to
give you protection well the reason I
got a machine gun was because somebody's
treating happening when they tried to
kill me DEA decided to move me out of
town and promised me I was gonna put him
in the winter potential problem they
tell me how to leave town because the
Haitian was arrested in that time not
only to kill me
poke you one of the aliens too as well
in this case okay now I don't want to go
into that in great detail at this point
that's been dealt with is that correct
yeah well I don't want you to be
reluctant about it yeah you hasn't been
dealt with or hasn't it walking on the
zone okay all right did you where did
you get this machine gun the machine gun
came brother hanging a guy named France
I'm Pedro this fully automatic huh I
believe so easy to get in Miami buries
lots of people running around with
machine guns
yes you know that do you know that
Justin have you seen a lot of them yes I
got two maybe a year - or recent
purchase right my - was the reason since
the Haitians you know became how became
Italian for the Asian but how do you
know this I mean you say
you're a businessman you've never been a
truck you haven't been arrested there's
obviously no arrest record until
recently you've been out of trouble
what do you do operate normal businesses
in an atmosphere with machine guns
around you
Cynthia had a much in gone before in my
life
I bought those machine gun half the DEA
thrown me industry but apart from that
apart from that problem you said you've
seen other people with machine guns how
does that occur in the seafood business
you know it's better easy to buy machine
gun in Miami
okay so what you're telling me is that
the drug trafficking that was going on
in the seafood business was plentiful
enough that this was something that you
came across even in your business which
was not tainted with drugs right is that
correct yes okay and you knew of these
other companies that were involved in
this narcotics trafficking
but you saw machine guns so much ago yes
and your father
somebody coming on and you know even six
months before I was arrested I was
involving this deal we report to u.s.
customs warehouse would have guns
well mr. Quint Anna what do you think
about the narcotics trade now stay away
from well stay away from how does it
pretty much ruined your life totally
totally have you had to borrow money
from your father
yes sir how much money you have that
kind of money to help you for a long
time yeah and your wife and family it's
been difficult hasn't it even a new
trailer well I want to I want to thank
you I know the DEA is appreciative of
your assistance we've been working with
them and I'm appreciative of their
assistance and I know that
they're officers who have met with us or
are anxious to cooperate further and
clearly intend to guarantee that your
protection is provided for and we
certainly want to express our
appreciation for that I also want to
thank you for being willing to come
forward I know you've been very scared I
know you've had a lot of pressure on you
and I know that none of this is easy
it's totally out of the norm of your
life but I assure you it's somewhat out
of the norm of our lives too and the
importance of your testimony is is not
to be underestimated I think you have
told us about personal dealings with a
man who controls perhaps 40,000 or who
knows the exact number today because of
the turmoil in Haiti but clearly an
insidious known terrorist kind of
organization within a country that's
rendered a whole people helpless before
it and their level of violence is famous
infamous I should say the situation in
Haiti is one of chaos today obviously I
think our policy is perhaps and not
helped but I'm not here to discuss that
now what I want to underscore is that
here's a military man who can run with
impunity through customs who can steal
paintings from people who can take
tortoise shells off and do whatever he
wants have an airstrip at a ranch live
in the same kind of splendor as a
Noriega or some of these other thugs
around the world and who is busy cutting
deals to put narcotics on the streets of
the United States and I am delighted
that the US attorney has moved I applaud
him for doing so I think these recent
efforts by our US Attorney's are vital
and it is very important that we send
this kind of signal that we're simply
not going to tolerate this what is what
has also been
scored by your testimony as here is yet
another country not even listed in the
international narcotics report of the
United States State Department this year
is a major transshipment point from
which we know narcotics are flowing into
this country yet another country with
tentacles to the Medellin Cartel with
individuals that you have named who have
those linkages with money that has been
flowing and with an obvious trafficking
network that is again I say polluting
the streets of our country and I think
your testimony has been most important
in helping us to understand that clearly
we have to again revisit strategy and
and more but if the leaders of these
countries are allowed to do this you
know we're going to be fighting a long
uphill battle for a long time to come if
you know kernels playing generals with
enormous power all of whom no matter
what their rank entitled in their pseudo
military status is in fact dictator are
able to pull these kinds of efforts so
we've got our work cut out for us and
until we start to get tough on elections
in these countries on the government's
that we're willing to certify as
legitimate governments on the aid
programs and on our international
cooperative efforts we are gonna
undermine the efforts of the Sherman
Griffiths and Eddie Burns who are giving
their lives in the effort to try to
fight drugs so that's what I think your
testimony is all about today mr. Quinn
Donna and I am appreciative of the fact
that you've come forward like this and I
think notwithstanding the fact that you
got tangled up in a criminal enterprise
you're paying a high price for it right
now and we obviously need and to pay
something of a price to assist you in
doing that and I hope we're going to do
that for certain we will reconvene
tomorrow I will be we have the immunity
order from the court now so we will be
granting the immunity the limited
immunity to mr. Michael Palmer
who is supposed to be arriving here this
afternoon and we will be dealing with
that and of course the evening because
of the open endedness of some of those
dealings I cannot say to a certainty
whether he will be the first witness
tomorrow or mr. million Rodriguez but we
will be proceeding with a witness
tomorrow morning and then we have a
couple of matters which by necessity we
have to hold in a closed session and I
will be announcing tomorrow where we'll
be proceeding with respect to the rest
of the schedule tomorrow we will convene
at 10 a.m. and we stand in Riyadh mr.
Quint Anna you want to say something
sorry I like to read about five minutes
treatment that I may be delighted to
have you read a statement can you can
you just read it slowly oh well okay if
you do you want to do it that way okay
if you just do it a sentence at a time
and you can translate as we go okay so
would you pull a microphone close to you
Thank You mr. malson your Edisto kumite
miembro de la prensa mizuna present just
let me just answer ten here do you have
a translation yes
are you have a translation yeah all
right thank you
distinguished gentlemen of this
Investigative Committee members the
press and all of this present podium
episiotomy they're getting all about the
mailpoet are present and data committee
meeting at the para por todo mi consumed
internally with raava hey get me for you
today is a very special day for me since
I have the opportunity to share before
this Investigative Committee of my
knowledge of drug trafficking in this
hemisphere memory cometo agreement
estado
durante más tvoaqui in washington
communication mental energy oblong poses
education apropos young handsome me
personally familia na seuk enoch cuatro
semana que morton communication i would
like to thank the members of this
committee for all the help they've
extended to me during my stay in
washington and especially mr. Jack Bloom
dedication and - and at the same kind
time concern for me and my family over
the last four weeks in which we've been
in contact you know they're not a part
they mean you normally familiar again a
thousand thanks on behalf of my family
and I know chuckles impossible and
Daniel Purcell perilous you know I think
I saw a koala Eric Eric Eric refugio he
wrote unto them you gonna come on Tommy
in polymer already familiar many things
have happened over the last year related
to this case that have required
sacrifice and caused pain for myself and
members of my family auto parts in the
calaboose Aria Italian desuka be
delusional coma testimonial eulogy
Metacomet a party the middle has the
grandpa yeah super loss your paella
today all indications are that the
nightmare is coming to its end with my
testimony today before this committee I
think that part of my debt to this great
country and its people has been paid
told ominous we are committed Lori you
know so he does assume everyone makes
mistakes in the course of the lifetime
and I'm no exception appeal me Familia
amigos yell of a Alice's funeral home
way to go meet I just said to him Emma's
since Aurora been deviant but I have
recognized these mistakes and I only ask
of my family friends and society in
general and this committee that it
accept my most sincere repentance
muchas horas intercept remember on kim
so-eun many present today will ask Who I
am
yes implementors you are nominated by
the Romanian okay transit Impala Khaled
there are koalas the cookies you are
parisology Forenza
drogas I am simply one more citizen of
this country of the millions who passed
daily down the streets of any city but
with one difference drugs Rosa Rosa de
la la vie Mutola television travel
periodicals ave SE que la fameuse
que ya no no no cousin division drugs
one of the words most commonly used by
our society today we see it every day on
TV radio newspapers to the point that we
see it so many times that we've become
indifferent to it in tiempos pasado
cumbia del mercado
limit Avari khofifah motion hydrogen at
Ohlone Bella nitrous acid on consuming
sollu sudha murthy in the past it was a
vise with the market limited to the rich
and the famous today drugs reach all
levels of our society with their message
of death and destruction boy podium our
city enemy gonna come but econo
combating environment and the Kuno our
Monroe the day we could say that our
enemies do not combat us with arms they
found the new weapon drugs muchos anos
differente a minute Osuna deloitte also
knew no sin even yacumo no no no how
poor you're insane here for many years
different u.s. administration's taught
us were pointed out to us the danger of
communism and communism has not been
able to triumph nor to convince us as to
its ideology naquadah reactor or emo
universe monnat07 super economical
militant para compartir load on the gear
equivalent how you learn the economic
Amenti me little mate they are mucho an
apparent value in continuity
come open via moon do maintain later
they talked about terrorism and our
leaders once again used their economic
and military might to combat them
wherever they might be providing
economic and military aid to many of our
parents allies in Latin America and
internationally
Pocoyo knows who seemed a little imp I
say no to my video University of preview
combat in a balcony moon yet there or
even terrassa when negocio in control
we support governments we placed leaders
in countries of our hemisphere who
although according to statements of
several previous witnesses apparently
combated communism and terrorism at the
same time dealt in drugs
confronting panama haiti in elemental
area Nicaragua that today is the sad
story we face in Panama in Haiti and
naturally the stars of the game Cuba and
Nicaragua man tenemos ordinary a little
difficult political hit device today we
maintain open arrest orders for
political figures from cuba nicaragua
but with no possibility of having these
individuals tried in this country el
próximo a linear super tomatoes
para man he taught us in the capital
Chavez you know real continual I think
I'll pull up on the menu the next in
line is supposedly the best at you ally
of the u.s. Panama and all indications
are that mr. Noriega show will continue
at the expense of the Panamanian people
problem you betcha mentira for a yummy
pasta lucha political control communing
more in america's in trouble well our
leaders of the present administration
study how to resolve the problem which
though it seems like a lie was created
and maintained by they themselves for
the sake of their policy of combating
communism in Central America
I mean para la gente en el Raton say
taco mean balloon well they turned the
blight blind eye to drug trafficking and
money laundering in Panama apparently
the mouse was eating the lion water
hygiene and now the new kid on the block
Haiti in response a question mark
whoever hundred thousand euros config
controls tratando in Travelport American
Valencia means you now figure a
political military in traffic or oil not
as a producer simplemente sales and como
transition and to add other players to
this game against the US from which
drugs have been confiscated in attempts
to get them into American ports where
political and military figures linked to
drug trafficking have been mentioned
where drugs are produced or that are
simply used for transshipment we have
the following quote allies unquote in
our hemisphere
their usual ante Enrique Camarena
support pero the Casa como una girls
Mexico where a DEA agent and his
assistant were assassinated Enrique
Camarena the supposed assassin or
murderer Carlos Quintero rests
comfortably in a Mexican prison under us
Anders Holm in refuge of Mister
matta-ballesteros swallow the moussaka
as I said the Padmini truth is yeah
possibly culantro Venezuela where the
Minister of Justice was just dismissed
because of his links to
Bolivia but a few USA no Soares tambien
numero uno Aurora Bolivia the refuge of
mr. Suarez and also number one drug
producer Peru Segundo they are like
mundo Peru the second largest producing
coca leaf producing country in the world
Colombia Castle Academy hotel de Cali
Colombia home to the Medellin and Cali
cartels Bahamas PI given me the tow
vehicle they are evaluating Bahamas the
country is just one of Jeffrey Kerala I
just want to break in for one minute
because we received some important news
that reflects on what you said and I
just I want to pick up on one thing
you're talking now about these different
places where people are sitting
unmolested and we've been raising that
issue over a period of time mr. Vogel
this morning didn't testify to but was
going to and Ken still to some of mr.
matta-ballesteros involvements I I want
to remind people about mr. bonds Terrace
and I'm sorry to break in but this is
important when two DEA when a DEA agent
was murdered in American da-jin
in Mexico brutally Juan ramón
matta-ballesteros escaped drug officials
from Mexico drug officials said that one
week after Camarena and Zavala were
reported missing these the two people
who were killed they gave Mexican
authorities information that Ballesteros
was in an apartment in Mexico City and
they sought Mexican help and arresting
him the Mexican authorities delayed
acting for two days and Ballesteros
escaped
John lon the administrator of the Drug
Enforcement Administration said that he
was disturbed by Mexico's failure to
cooperate which he termed and I quote
him at best in action at worst
complicity Ballesteros is one of the
most significant cocaine traffickers in
the world we've referred to him several
times in the course of these hearings
this
time we referred to him in our hearings
last time according to anti-narcotics
officials he was the contact between the
Colombian cocaine suppliers and the
Mexican smugglers he heads the so called
Padrino trafficking organization which
supplies cocaine to the United States
you've heard of that haven't you and it
operates in Peru Mexico Colombia and
Honduras correct
Ballesteros who's a Honduran national
and I said this yesterday has been
wanted by the United States law
enforcement authorities since 1971 when
he escaped from a federal prison camp at
Eglin Air Force Base in Florida
he'd been serving a three-year sentence
for passport violations and illegal
entry in the United States he's also
wanted in New York on federal charges of
conspiring to important distribute
cocaine and according to an arrest
warrant and complaint he took part in a
conspiracy between 1976 and 82 to import
five shipments of at least 660 pounds
each from Colombia to the United States
by way of Guadalajara from Guadalajara
incidentally the Padrino organization
funneled cocaine into New York Miami and
Los Angeles DEA has been investigating
bank accounts around the world where
Ballesteros is believed to have the
positive drug money between August of
1984 and 1985
drug agency officials seized 3600 pounds
of cocaine 16 million dollars in cash
three properties and several planes from
the Padrino organization they believe
the ring is able to smuggle up to 60,000
pounds of pure cocaine into the United
States annually taking in up to 30
million dollars a month the ring has
also brought up bought up legitimate
businesses including ranches hotels a
third of the country's only privately
owned airline in addition that's
Honduras and in addition the Internal
Revenue Service has outstanding liens on
the group worth 36 million dollars so
Ballesteros was then arrested
in Cartagena and Colombia the DEA
provided the Colombians with the
information that helped to get his
arrest
apparently he offered to pay off the
Colombian police four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to unrest him which
they declined initially less than a year
later he walked out of a Bogota prison
in a uniform belonging to one of the
guards that his agent said subpoenaed
for many times their annual pay he
reportedly paid $1,000,000 bribe to the
prison officials and 13 days later he
turned up in his native Honduras which
has no extradition treaty with the
United States and he surrendered to
authorities to answer earlier charges of
kidnapping and murder he spent a brief
period in jail again buying his way to
freedom
he has been residing in Honduras up
until today he lives in Tegucigalpa in a
large house he's reportedly worth about
two billion dollars and despite the fact
that they have remained the eighth
largest a country as I mentioned
yesterday in the amount of aid they get
from us Ballesteros has been existing in
that status with impunity I have just
received word and I thought it was
important in view of our insistence on
this issue and others and our interest
in it that today
Ramon Ballesteros has been arrested by
Honduran authorities this morning in
response apparently to concerns
expressed in the United States about
this case and I suppose the big question
now will be whether or not we can move
with Honduras
that he comes to justice and I hope that
the pressure of these efforts can or has
or will perhaps produce a further effort
with respect to that but I thought in
light of your statement about those
linkages it's nice to try to end this on
something of a potentially positive note
you want to complete that and it's a
couple of you know couple mins also
police say Graham told Emily warning
systems O'Neill
also they leaves a major producer of
marijuana shipped to the US am I can
certainly say asesinato Paris in all
control we can't draw Muhammad Cano's
seem sellers is Rosina Dorian in
Washington Jamaica in which there's been
76 murders related to Jamaican drug
traffickers so far this year in
Washington DC reporter government Agana
no you're not freakin see on the scene
to warrant he said kilos ago Galena
unless your integrity American Republic
in which there were was a confiscation
of 146 kilograms of coke cocaine at
Montecristi Ecuador came upon tráfico
solamente how or abroad reproduce report
on Ecuador which began only as a
transshipment country is now also a
producer an exporting country Hawaii was
also purchase at the villa political
area trafficking Paraguay with new
suspicions of certain political figures
being involved in trafficking a Costa
Rica can Co see the transition and Costa
Rica which has always been a
transshipment point total I said not to
continent in support I mean tell you
what Rose thank you so can see simply
impossibly they pointed the equator
sauropod el tema k prabang atolls needle
all these Latin American and Caribbean
countries supposedly our allies almost
find it impossible to come to any
agreement on matters proposed by the US
put on yellow soon to overalls cleaning
who knows when asana no prob it as
regards drugs they have a unison voice
we don't have funds for combating drugs
cuando vino a casa milà proponent ebony
directamente control traffic antes todo
el mundo cigar sonali boom when the US
government proposes they didn't
intervene directly against the
traffickers everyone claims to national
you're canceling temper simulator
Rosalia Oh traffic on telecommunicator
little st. an example tempo limit allah'
he combatant improper and of our policy
how many rows effective Allah and the
king and the few who accept direct
intervention and the allies of the
traffickers and the Communists and the
terrorists take steps to ensure that
such intervention be for a limited time
and with sufficient publicity to
minimize its effect before they arrive
yesin para que no se never beat them in
turn assuring its total failure so that
it not be repeated phenomenal opposite
v1 Native American forum on dunes like a
sama for the first time three enemies of
the US have found an effective way of
destroying the American system forming a
triangular alliance that is called
kaboom communism which is the ideology
there anymore bro somos terrorism the
armed wing and drug trafficking which
provides the financing the principal
kima's the main shareholders of this new
triangle who else
cool Cuba representing the ideology
different the group where the yellow
represent an dr. or remove different
guerrilla groups representing terrorism
LFL many miserable a may be seen over
the Columbia same duralumin also the
Peru Alfaro each of one Arizona for
example the FMLN of El Salvador the m-19
of Colombia Shining Path guerrillas of
Peru the Alfaro of Eve a group in
Ecuador the seen tornadoes in Honduras
and others and drug trafficking
controlled by the merely
medellin cartel controls of a super
mobility no enemy but apparently the
reagan-bush administration has already
found the solution as to how to combat
this new sworn enemy a Plaza wasn't
proposed the plan is based on three
steps premier brothel no bra no peace a
present the bush Ephrata force control
they first step appointing Vice
President Bush as head of the Task Force
on drugs vaso happiness in a political
sound or a sentimiento The Tempest and
an America latina ruin he has lately
been very busy in his political
aspirations and not very
interested in the recent events going on
in Latin America related to drugs
Segundo is a combinatorial imposingly
secondly cutting the funds to different
agencies that combat drugs making it
difficult if not impossible for them to
function effectively Mucha want but in
TLC under the window him to somebody I'm
already a mother and since all wars have
to have soldiers an army has been
created of men with wit with much will
valor and dedication made up of two
thousand nine hundred young men and
women called the da la vía
those informal mr. Amendola da Matta me
or no traffic on Telemundo the DEA the
Drug Enforcement Administration possibly
the virus most feared by the world's
drug traffickers so let me tell you
jealousy well come on a hint episode I
mean this year
Tina carefrontation and I using a couple
he moved to man-whore Amalia keep on
okay you didn't even people in me to
serve in Vienna the DEA with its limited
resources in this unequal struggle and
with what may be the worst paid agents
in our judicial system has to face
ruthless and much better armed and
equipped enemies who have no financial
restrictions whatsoever on us attention
hoppity alternative otros who are into
him Allison are you an illusion
Missy work on daughter of agonda heroin
the DEA which in the years of its
existence has lost 34 of its agents plus
many more wounded in this unequal
struggle against drug traffickers
because he only Kamala's the same time
as he thinks you copper do Solomon teen
or anything in comparison with the FBI
which has been in existence for over 60
years and has lost only twenty nine
agents dress on you something total
years because since I was young a ready
sir these boys and I call them boys
because their average age is twenty four
to thirty three years old leave their
homes every day without knowing whether
they will return because he simply
individual maintain parejas and they
won't know mono mono negotiated over lo
cual la santé lovely happily look it's a
pony they work at any time of day or
night almost always individually or in
pairs dealing hand to hand in drug deals
which makes them very vulnerable
to the danger to which they expose
themselves I mean your uncle see also
people other things like I can see two
nuts are in difficulty will not be
totally mutual they also carry with them
that defense equipment which consists of
an identification badge a pistol and a
lot of guts somebody who goes in
Interpol they almost always work in the
shadows without any public recognition
they are the unknown heroes of the
struggle against drugs in Kony do they
constitute the backbone and the struggle
against drugs the unknown heroes develop
NRC recommendable it was amazing
even when they died fulfilling their
duty they received barely any of the
public recognition they deserved that is
the DA has a monopoly on trade we mean
by Superman Bahia joy cetera we are US
citizens were born and raised amidst
heroes since we were children we began
to admire Superman Batman GI Joe and so
on you said okay boy reconocimiento know
some people beside you said okay
anomalous in your normal senior st.
they're worried no today I would like to
mention one hero who though I know he is
against all types of recognition I his
former adversary have to mention
gentlemen he is what II know Special
Agent of the DA no sir no sir I said
inter lucha sino también de la raza
pursue pursue Taoiseach professionally
more we become critical so not only do I
have to thank him for having opened my
eyes in this struggle but I also have to
thank him for his persistence and
professionalism thanks to which we were
able to bring this case to a close
you ain't worried no Tommy no no
synonymy yeah you know I would like to
note that agent Karina was by my side
the day they tried to assassinate me and
him I owe him my life
thanks once again every night at all
option buckling at the comité a neuron
tell the permit a killer Anthony Pursell
significant completion I'm Italian
tasted like coprocessor para mi familia
and to end I would like to express my
greatest thanks to all of those involved
in this committee who in the course the
last year have given their understanding
friendship and moral assistance during
this long process for myself and my
family
in your stove en Miami and the following
persons talk VA Miami Stokes the agent
of Miami
Morris DA in Miami more it's at the
agent of Miami
Alex Nora like us Costas of Miami Alex
Newell art a US Customs of Miami gents s
Matai FBI in Miami James Mathias VI
agent in Miami you me know how many your
locale is Joe said f it's like no you
sterling tell him Salah policy they're
watching me and my new local friends
Joseph twigs the second of the
Intelligence Division of the Washington
police yell a mission and detective Carl
Schaffer personal ain't official
Williams safe with the US Customs and my
special personal friend u.s. customs
agent William C Weaver thank you very
much for your time
well mr. Quinton I want to thank you on
behalf of all of them for your
generosity and calling them all to mind
I think if we left more of our more of
our witnesses and others in the custody
of the DEA they might come up here and
break the budget at the Congress with
that kind of heckle aid but I want to
thank you I think that clearly your life
has been in danger and I know you are
very emotional about this as you want to
be and we recognize the link that has
been created between you and they and we
are very appreciative as I said earlier
for their support and their help and I
know that you know both of you going to
be cooperating this these days go on so
you should again thank you for taking
time and also thank you for that
statement it reflects I know the last
year or in a bit has been something of a
nightmare for you and has steeped you
and your knowledge about narcotics in
ways that you never thought you might be
so I appreciate your outlook and I want
to thank you again for your patience we
will stand in recess until 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning